frédéric bon suisse cette caravane bien
sûr mais des migrants y en a des
dizaines de millions dans le monde oui
céline parce qu'en fait le mot migrants
ça concerne aussi bien les gens qui ont
été persécutés qui veulent même par
exemple trouver de nouvelles conditions
de vie des meilleurs emplois donc quand
on regarde ces chiffres en 2000 il y
avait 173 millions à travers la planète
donc 113 millions de migrants en 2018 en
est rendu à 258
et si la tendance se maintient en 2050
on pourrait dépasser les 400 millions de
migrants alors évidemment c'est des
chiffres assez important 258 millions ça
veut dire ça représente 3 4 % de la
population mondiale n'ont qu'une
personne sur trente est considéré comme
un migrant
si on regarde les femmes elles occupent
48 % de ceux 258 millions et 14 % sont
des jeunes de moins de 20 ans maintenant
si on regarde justement le chiffre de ce
qui concerne les gens qui ont été
déplacés soit par des conflits ou soit
par des problèmes écologiques
c'est quand même plus de 68 millions de
personnes et dans ce chiffre on retrouve
en fait 28 millions de réfugiés et de
gens qui ont demandé le statut de
demandeur d'asile
enfin un chiffre qui fait partie de 758
millions
ce sont les 50 millions de personnes
illégal donc ceux qui font peur à des
gens comme monsieur tron qui ont décidé
de rentrer dans des pays de façon tout à
fait illégale alors de ces migrants d'où
vient-il et où est-ce qu'ils vont alors
d'abord l'origine mais sans grande
surprise on parle ici de l'asie j'y suis
rentré j'ai prise parce que l'enfant ça
concerne aussi bien la russie que la
chine que l'afghanistan que la syrie
dans kent à 110 millions qui proviennent
de la ensuite eh bien on à l'europe il
ya d'importants flux migratoires 61
millions de personnes ensuite vous avez
l'amérique latine et caraïbes 38
millions ou encore l'afrique 36 millions
maintenant où vont ces gens mais
regardez ces graphiques on parle encore
une fois de l'asie c'est la plus grande
proportion de haut niveau de la
destination 80 millions de personnes
ensuite pas très loin biya l'europe vous
savez tous les caravanes de migrants qui
viennent de l'afrique qui s'en vont en
allemagne par exemple
ensuite vous avez l'amérique du nord 58
millions ou encore ben on voit des
chiffres beaucoup plus faibles
évidemment pour l'afrique et pour ce qui
concerne évidemment les américains
tiennent bon alors cette crise
d'immigrants elle n'est pas près de
s'arrêter les nations unies
cherche un moyen justement de faire en
sorte que ce soit dans un bain de ce que
ça se fasse un peu plus dans l'ordre
cette migration voilà et donc on a en
fait 192 pays qui ont qui sont entendus
pour faire un pacte mondial pour les
migrations
le problème c'est qu'il ya déjà des
fissures dans le sillon de solidarité il
ya plusieurs pays qui ont dit déjà on ne
signera pas cet accord le mois prochain
par exemple il à l'autriche et à la
pologne la tchéquie la bulgarie ou
encore la roumanie pourtant c'est juste
la bonne volonté est là c'est même pas
obligatoire comme paktiya pas de
sanction voilà pas de contrainte
merci fallait en plus